We've got 20 14 to 19-year-old kids...
...to get them to do a kind of "ready, steady, cook" style cooking day.
We've split them up into groups.
We've given them each an apprentice...
...and given them all fresh ingredients.
The theme of the day is fish, so we've given them four pieces of fish each.
And they've got to fillet, gut, take the gills out,...
...so it's probably stuff that they've never ever done before.
The food we've got here today, I literally got in the kitchen about seven o'clock in the morning.
I just grabbed a little bit of everything:...
...olive oils, vinegars, olives, a massive array of herbs and vegetables and...
...some of the fresh pasta that we make in the restaurant.
I just brought it down here and it's absolutely fantastic.
These kids are using probably some of the best produce that you can possibly get.
Yeah, it's going really well.
We've got a few who are quite determined.
They know what they want to do.
We just help them put some dishes together.
In the sense that showing other people what cooking is about now,...
...you don't have to know how to cook this or that.
It's just like getting stuff in there.
Just do it, it's fun.
You don't know what you can do until you do it really.
We're all here for the same reason.
Everyone's here trying to cook and have fun...
...and we're trying to show them how fun cooking actually can be.
I think that Fifteen's involvement with these things is just fantastic.
It's just so much fun,...
...and I feel like I am making a little bit of an impression via Fifteen and it's great.
I just feel fantastic about it.
And I think it's something in the middle of their summer holiday that they're gonna remember.